[Music]  Harris Jackson gets candid in a  bombshell tell-all interview detailing  her issues with depression drugs and her  dad's death Michael Jackson's daughter  opens up to Rolling Stone magazine  claims she was sexually assaulted at age  14 but didn't tell anybody the 18 year  old reveals she first tried to commit  suicide at 15 years old followed by  multiple attempts quote it was just  self-hatred low self-esteem  she says the self-loathing came after  the King of Pop died in 2009  [Music]  and get this Parra says she's convinced  the late musician was murdered quote he  would drop hints about people being out  to get him and at some point he was like  they're gonna kill me one day Michael's  daughter also breaks her silence on how  he handled child molestation claims  quote picture your parent crying to you  about the world hating him for something  he didn't do